hey you guys flickers of fear time time
for us to talk about yet another horror
movie now this is one that a lot of
people had recommended to me and a lot
of people um you know i've seen it like
on a lot of people different people's
lists and [ __ ] like that um a lot of
kind of like why haven't i heard about
this movie this is so great it's kind of
like an unseen gem or something like
that i've seen it called a slasher movie
i would call it more like survival
horror
this came out back in 2008 and it's
british and it's called eden lake and it
actually got kind of some big names in
it michael fassbender is uh is in it
this was kind of well this was like
before prometheus so i guess this was
kind of like before he was super super
famous at least in the united states so
it's like interesting to see him
in a smaller film like this um you know
what is essentially like i said a
survival horror piece
and it's interesting too i actually
i had never heard of this but now that
it exists it's like it's really funny to
me so i guess that there is a sub genre
of british horror it's not massive or
anything like that there's like a few
movies in it but it's called hoodie
horror where it's basically like
you're having uh these things where a
bunch of kind of like working class thug
type teens or chavs in the uh british
parlots are terrorizing you know nice
middle class people or whatever and that
this definitely falls into that camp
that said though this movie it's re it's
good it's like it's like a simple
it's like a really simple premise like a
lot of these kind of movies are it's
very gruesome it's very brutal it's not
like gory
but it's really really violent and like
a lot of the violence is like really
really visceral and as i said it's just
it's pretty much just like a straight
ahead
chase survival in the woods type of
movie but like i said you know [ __ ]
doesn't have to be complicated to be
good this was actually very scary had a
lot of like tension to it it was just
really really well done well shot the
writer and director on this was james
watkins who also did the woman in black
uh the one with daniel radcliffe in it
because it's been made a couple of times
you know the the adaptation of the novel
i think i did i'm pretty sure i did a
book review i don't think i talked about
the movie yet though but i actually did
like that daniel radcliffe
you know adaptation this is completely
opposite to that whereas the woman in
black was much more like a very staid
english ghost story and i like those too
this is very much like just a brutal
fast-paced action-packed
gory bloody violent um you know survival
horror in the tradition of
british films since time immemorial uh
the ending is like super super bleak i
don't know i guess i'll probably uh say
what happens at the end because like i
said this isn't a brand new movie it
came out back in 2008 so it's you know
it's quite old and uh this is actually
pretty easy movie to get hold of i
believe i watched it on 2b and i think
it's on a couple of other streaming
services as well so but like i said if
you don't have any other streaming
services you can watch it for free on
tubi at least in the united states so
you know if you want to go check it out
definitely go check it out because it's
really really uh worth it
so what the setup for this is michael
fassbender plays a dude named steve
and kelly riley plays his girlfriend
named jenny who is a i guess she's like
a nursery school teacher elementary
school teacher something like that
so
it's kind of like it starts out on a
friday and she's kind of saying goodbye
to all her students and everything it's
like you know have a good weekend
whatever
so it's established kind of early on
that he's going to
take her out uh you know they're going
out for the weekend they're going
camping to this lake although it's not
actually a lake it's just kind of like
it's like a flooded quarry type
situation and he's basically like okay
well this uh section this where this
lake is they're actually gonna fill in
the lake and they're gonna put kind of
like high-end homes there and it's such
a beautiful location and it's such a
shame that they're gonna like pave it
all over and put houses so this is this
will probably be like the last time that
we can go there and see all this natural
beauty before they build uh you know
fancy houses all over it so she kind of
like makes a lot of jokes about you know
oh you know my best friend like her you
know boyfriend's taking her to paris for
the weekend but okay we're going to some
flooded quarry but she's not being like
mean about it um but he's like no it's
super beautiful wait till you see it and
he's also unbeknownst to her planning to
propose so he's got like the engagement
ring and everything like that so now
before they get to the site
uh there's some kind of foreshadowing in
the sense of they stop at this place i
don't i guess it's kind of like i didn't
know it's like a hotel or like an inn or
like somewhere where they can eat or
something like that and um it's kind of
like there's kind of all these
sort of trashy ass people staying there
um you know a bunch of screaming
teenagers and screaming kids and a bunch
of like kind of
borish you know adults
and uh it's kind of funny because him
and the girlfriend are like sitting at a
bench like eating or drinking a beer or
whatever
and one of the kid one of this kid is
like screaming his head off and uh steve
says at one point he's like man that kid
could use a real smack and then like you
know the mom like smacks the kid and
then he's kind of like makes this face
like wait did i actually like want for
that to happen because it totally just
did at least to shut the kid up you know
what i'm saying but it's like so because
this is kind of like like i said a
hoodie horror in the sense that it's
like teenagers that are being the
victimizers so i think this was a really
good um kind of economical way of
setting up
you know the kind of area that this is
and i will say too that even though this
movie
seemed to have gotten like largely you
know 80 85 positive reviews
in the british press some uh some felt
that the movie kind of demonized the
working classes i can see that but i
don't really i mean i don't know i don't
think it demonizes the working classes
any more than you know like an american
film like the hills have eyes or like
that because i mean obviously they're
not saying all working-class people are
like this it's just like this one area
these people are kind of like shitty and
so i didn't really you know i didn't
really like think that it was making a
statement
on all working-class people as a whole
it was just talking about this
particular type of
working-class person um you know that is
just these kind of thuggish child
abusing
you know what i mean just these kind of
trashy-ass people it was just kind of
like that and that's kind of what this
area was like a lot of people that live
there they so they kind of like stay at
this place uh you know pub tavern
whatever it is and then like the next
morning they set out and they go to the
site and it is beautiful although i mean
if it was me i'd have been like yeah i
think i would have rather gone to paris
instead because it's like it's basically
just a lake i'm like it's nice but
i've seen those you know what i mean
it's it's not
mind-blowing or this is not the grand
canyon or anything like that but okay
so
he's like cheapskate i guess i don't
know that's kind of what i thought so
they kind of go and like they lay on the
the beach and they get everything set up
and whatever and they're like oh my god
it's so awesome and so idyllic and
everything now i will say too that
there's a little bit of a of more
foreshadowing when they actually get to
the place
and they kind of find this kid in the
woods who looks like he's collecting
bugs or something like that he's
supposed to be like say like a nerdy kid
or whatever and he's like collecting
bugs and he's like writing stuff down
and they're just you know she's a
teacher she's like hey what you doing or
whatever and he won't answer and then
he's just like i'm not supposed to talk
to strangers you know what i mean she's
just like yeah you're right okay so
we'll just leave you alone and bye so
they just kind of take off so like i
said they go to this beach they kind of
set everything up they're laying there
it's lovely they're having a wonderful
time they start making out and all this
other [ __ ] and then a whole bunch of
rowdy ass annoying ass
teenagers show up mostly boys of you
know varying ages from maybe like 12 to
16 somewhere around there and one girl
who i think is that same chick that was
on game of thrones i can't remember was
she like one of the i can't remember
like um
what character she played it was because
i haven't watched game of thrones but i
just know because i've seen her face
like in the memes and stuff so yeah so
later she would be in game of thrones
but yeah she was in this uh so it's like
a bunch of teenagers they're doing
obnoxious teenager [ __ ] like you know
they have really loud music on and
they're all like screaming at each other
and like wow
you know what i mean it's like that kind
of crap and i'm just like
i'm like oh my god i hope all these kids
die but yeah
which is probably not the intent of the
filmmakers it's always but every time i
see these movies um these kind of like
kids gone bad movies and i've done like
you know i've seen a lot of movies like
that and i've even read some books where
you know i've reviewed like you know
baby teeth and you know books like that
and then like movies like you know we
need to talk about kevin and stuff where
it's just kind of like they're trying to
set up it's like oh a child and they're
so innocent and what happens like when
they're sociopaths i'm like i don't like
just because they're a kid i just feel
like at some point you just kind of like
yeah they just
you just need to go i'm sorry and these
kids are definitely kind of like that
because these kids are just sucky it's
like most of them i mean yeah there's
it's kind of like a group like a lord of
the flies type of situation i guess but
one of them is clearly
like the lead psycho and the other ones
are just kind of like
coming along for the ride but once it
starts to go too far they're just kind
of like oh man we can't do this anymore
and you know and it gets to a point
where they can't really back out
but
still i mean they're all just really
obnoxious and i don't have a lot of
patience for that so i'm just kind of
like as soon as i saw him like all
acting up like that i'm just like just
drown whatever they also have like a
rottweiler because of course they do and
you know to me it's just
that's just really like such a such an
on the nose type of thing but yeah so
they have that and it's like they're not
directly like [ __ ] with the couple
but they're just kind of like looking
over there they're looking at them
through binoculars and they're just
being obnoxious i mean if it was me i
would have just like
just gotten up and left and just gone
somewhere else but of course michael
fassbender or steve is the character's
name he just thinks he's gonna go over
there because he's the adult and they're
the teenagers he's just gonna go over
there and say hey you know can you keep
it down like bro that's not gonna work
out the way you think it's going to
they're just going to go yeah [ __ ] you
what are you going to do and that's
exactly what happens so i think that
steve
was really a lot of his decisions if
he'd just like
ignored them or just like got up and
left and they just like went somewhere
else like none of the [ __ ] in this movie
would have happened um so probably he
should have done that but for whatever
reason and i guess that's kind of like
part of his character was that well i'm
the adult and i should be able to you
know what i mean it's just kind of like
i should be able to like tell them to
shut up and they should do it because
they're kids but i was like do you not
know how teenagers work or you know what
i mean and there's more of them than you
you know what i mean you're just one
dude and one lady and they're like five
or six of them you know and some of them
are like not kids kids they're like
teenagers so like 16 year olds so
probably they could just beat you to
death and probably you should just like
leave it alone but the fact that he
won't leave it alone really leads to uh
tragedy in this movie so like i said he
goes over there tells him to like hey
can you knock it off and of course they
say [ __ ] off we're not going to
and there's like at that point there's
like nothing more he can do so they just
go back over there and sit down
um you know so and they just kind of put
up with it and then finally like the
obnoxious teens like leave and of course
they have to like walk through
like right through like steve and
jenny's camp because they're dicks and
but you know steve and jen are like oh
finally like at last they're gone so
they set up their tent and they sleep
and then there's kind of like a scene at
night where you kind of think they came
back and it's just kind of like this
whole other thing that's like really
creepy and everything but it's fine the
next morning they get up and like they
brought some food and they opened the
cooler and it's like all full of bugs i
don't know if the kids put that to put
the bugs in there or if they just didn't
have it sealed properly or whatever but
so they don't have anything to eat so
they have to go like drive back into
town for breakfast and while they're
doing that they go to this diner and
you know they kind of say something
about the obnoxious teens or whatever to
the waitress and i'm just like dude keep
your mouth shut because that waitress is
probably like one of their moms or
something which it does kind of like you
know this is like a small town so they
all kind of know each other i'm just
like yeah just put the kibosh on that uh
might not want to let it known that hey
we're kind of these
like ponzi middle class people that are
in this like
basically savage town full of like
working-class savages so it's like you
know just kind of keep a low profile is
all i'm saying
they don't just don't know how to read
the room he doesn't know how to read the
room because i mean the whole time
jenny who is a teacher and has
experience with kids although much
younger ones she's just kind of like
death just like shut up you know what i
mean but he just won't because i don't
know why
so uh so yeah so while they're going
back to the campsite he sees a house and
he sees like all these bicycles like in
the front yard that belong to
the kids from the day before so again he
could just leave it alone and jenny
tells him hey just leave it alone just
let it go but of course he won't uh he
goes up to these people's house like
blocks their driveway for real
parks in front of their houses like hey
you stay in the car i'm gonna go inside
and talk to their parents i'm like
that's not gonna go well either because
obviously these kids are [ __ ]
obviously they were raised by [ __ ]
and this is also not gonna go the way
you think it's gonna go
so he goes in the house just straight up
walks in there because the door is
unlocked and he doesn't find anybody but
nothing like the dad comes home and he
has to like climb out the window it's
this whole situation so it's like
nothing really gets uh done about that
so then she's just like okay fine can we
just and then she gets yelled at by the
dad because she's blocking the driveway
when he comes home so it's like this big
like hostile situation
so
basically after that they're gonna stay
another night
and what ends up happening there is that
i guess she um kind of falls asleep
and
steve goes out scuba diving so he's like
not really watching the campsite
and so while that's happening steve
comes back and then they notice that
their beach bag is gone uh and their
beach bag had their phone and the you
know his wallet and the car keys and
then when they go back to where the car
is parked they discover that indeed the
[ __ ] obnoxious teens have stolen
their car
so basically so he goes to try to like
find him he's like they couldn't have
gone far so he goes and he actually
finds them they get into a scuffle
and he ends up accidentally
stabbing the main psycho's dog bonnie
the rottweiler he doesn't like he
doesn't mean to but it just kind of
happens in the scuffle so now of course
like all the kids are like on the
[ __ ] war path because that was the
only thing that this kid loved i guess
that's what they were trying to apply
now like the basically they get their
keys they get the car back and then but
the kids are like throwing rocks at them
and all this other kind of [ __ ] so it's
like the windshield breaks it's like
night time and you can't really see
where he's going and so he crashes into
a tree so then they're all like on foot
and then from that point forward it
becomes like a survival horror like
where they're just like running through
the woods they get separated and the
kids are like stalking them like through
the thing now what ends up happening is
that steve
actually gets taken by the kids because
like i said him and jenny get separated
and jenny like he's like you know go
hide and whatever and she does and then
he gets taken he gets like tied to a
pole and uh all the kids like take turns
essentially like torturing him uh you
know stabbing him in different places
you know doing like i think they stabbed
him in the balls they did it's all kind
of [ __ ] that they do what he and what
the main psycho kid does who i think his
name is brett and basically like even
though at this point all the other kids
are like you know brett dude chill out
it's like you know what i mean but
brett's like well we've gone too far we
can't go back now we have to kill him
and um i'm gonna film each of you
doing something to him like torturing
him you know i'm gonna film it so then
later like so you can't rat on me
because we've all because we're all
involved at this point so that's
basically what they do like i said it's
it's kind of like this whole back and
forth now where you know he's all [ __ ]
up but he ends up escaping jenny's like
trying to run away from them so it's
just kind of like this this whole like
situation like i said this part was like
really really good like really tense um
it's really really violent like i said
very bloody um there was actually one
scene where she was running through the
woods and she has shoes on she has like
little like converse type tennis shoes
or whatever and she's like running
through the she's running through the
woods and uh there's like some kind of
big spiky something or other like in the
grass and she just like steps in it goes
like all the way through her front and i
was just like oh it was like it was
awful but yeah so so it's a lot of that
kind of like very visceral like violence
to it
so as i said it ends up going and like i
said uh this came out in 2008 so from
this point on i'm gonna like spoil what
happens at the end like i said the third
act is pretty much all just like a chase
movie through the thing and it's one of
those movies where it just and i think
these are like the best kinds of kind of
action thriller survival horror ones
where the situation just keeps getting
worse and worse and worse and worse and
like i said because this is a british
movie um it's gonna get worse and worse
and worse and then the end is gonna be
like the [ __ ] like the [ __ ] worst
bleakest most depressing thing ever and
indeed that's what happens in this one
because what ends up happening is that
uh you know steve gets away like he's
you know he was tied to this pole or
whatever but he escapes but he's been
stabbed and [ __ ] like that so many times
that he's like losing uh too much blood
she they actually reunite and he tries
she tries to help him and she's gonna go
back into the town and everything like
that but it's just you know she's like i
you know i can't carry you with me we
don't have the car anymore because it's
all [ __ ] up so she and she doesn't
really know the way back to town uh she
finds the nerdy kid from the beginning
and she's like you gonna show me the way
back to town and he's like yeah i
totally will but you pretty much know
that he
even though the other the bully kids
were like picking on him earlier i i
kind of suspected i was like oh well he
wants to be one of the cool kids so he's
gonna like try and get in good with them
by
telling the kids where she is because
they've kind of like lost her in the
interim and that is indeed what happens
so she gets kind of led into an ambush
and then like i said there's this whole
like [ __ ] fight about it now
somewhere in the interim steve dies like
from his uh injuries and what ends up
happening is that the kids like tie
steve and jenny to a tree and then they
set steve on fire
um which is [ __ ] up they didn't really
think the [ __ ] through though because
the fire which is you know burning the
body or whatever it also um burns
through the rope that's holding her to
the tree or whatever so she gets away
and at which point like the kids make
kind of a miscalculation because they
put like a tire around the nerdy kid's
neck and then they're like if you don't
come back we're gonna burn this kid and
she kind of hesitates for a second she
like she said she's a teacher uh so she
doesn't want to see a kid get hurt but i
was just kind of like girl [ __ ] that kid
he like he turns you over to the bullies
it's like you don't know that brad
anything you know what i mean it's like
i know he was getting bullied too but
[ __ ] that kid seriously you got to get
away from here so that's indeed what she
does she just takes off and she's like
bye you know what i mean so they
actually do set the nerdy kid on fire so
again they're racking up quite a body
count all this [ __ ] happens she actually
does end up getting away she gets back
to the road and
flags down a car shitty thing is though
that when she gets in the car she's like
just take me to town you know oh my god
these kids are like stalking me or
whatever turns out like i said again
this is a very small town uh this kid is
the brother of one of the gang and he's
basically like yeah i'm out here looking
for my brother it's like he was supposed
to be home by now and at which point
she's like oh [ __ ] me and so he goes so
she doesn't say anything at first but
like he goes and parks uh you know
looking for the other kid and when she
sees that kid you know the the brother
gets out of the car and leaves the keys
in there luckily so she sees like him
meeting up with the gang member or
whatever and then she's like all right
[ __ ] this kid also and uh then she just
pops over to the driver's seat and it's
like bye again so like i said she's
pretty much the only person making smart
decisions in this like i said steve her
boyfriend kind of made stupid decisions
from the outset like i said if you just
let everything go i like i know how
annoying it is um you know you're out on
the beach and trying to have like a nice
romantic getaway or anything and like
all these stupid chads show up um i get
it like you want to go over there and
say something but just don't it's not
gonna go well um they don't respond well
to people asking them to do things um
you know what it means to just go
somewhere else just live your life and
just get on with it and you would have
still been alive steve but no you just
couldn't you just couldn't let it go you
had to keep pushing it you had to keep
going in their house you had to keep
like go go to their parents and [ __ ]
like that just just don't a lesson for
everybody there but yeah so she ends up
going in the car and then running over
uh you know she sees the girl from game
of thrones like running the road and i
was just kind of like hit that [ __ ] hit
that [ __ ] and then she's like she did
and i was like yes all right this is a
girl i can get behind
because she's like [ __ ] [ __ ] this kid
seriously so then like she ends up like
escaping and she actually ends up
killing one of the other kids too like
the youngest one not on purpose
necessarily but she just kind of sees
one of the kids like stocking up behind
her and this was the kid that was kind
of like reluctant but
i still didn't feel bad like she felt
bad obviously because this was like he
was 12 or something like that and he
really seemed like he didn't you know he
wasn't down with all the [ __ ] that was
going on but at that point like just
dude you know i've been through a lot
don't just like creep up behind me like
that you were with them earlier so
tough [ __ ] you know what i'm saying i'm
just a tough titty she felt bad i did
not i was just like yeah [ __ ] that kid
too uh but the thing about it though is
that since that kid ends up dying and
since a bunch of kids end up dying
so she gets back she steals this car and
goes back to this the first house she
comes to which uh at which a party is
going on and the first thing i thought
she goes in there and they're all like
partying in the backyard and she's all
[ __ ] up and covered with blood and
crap and just everything and she's just
like you know can you help me and at
first they seemed like really helpful
but i said oh you know what i bet these
are like the parents of the kids of the
gang you know what i mean and indeed
that is what happens and of course since
the apples don't fall too far from the
tree
once they find out like once they get a
phone call from one of those still
surviving kids in the woods and said hey
do you know what this [ __ ] did because
of course they put it all on her she
killed a little blonde kid um you know
she's a serial killer i don't think they
said that but it's like that's kind of
what they were trying to imply that it
was her fault that she had started it
she's so she's in this house with all of
these hostile people
and uh it goes about as well as you
would expect they don't actually show
what happens to her at the end it's just
like implied like through sound and
stuff but
obviously
these are not the types of people that
are going to call the cops and uh
especially because they think that this
woman has killed you know the dog and
also
you know some of their kids which she
did but
they didn't really i mean you know
context there was like context going on
and uh these these people just don't
really
seem to want to understand that because
these are their children uh you know
they're just kids they're just kids i'm
like yeah [ __ ] those kids you guys are
the ones that raised them and they're
all [ __ ] up but yeah so this is
basically like and i want to say too
that this was very much like her ending
up back at the house of the parents of
the people she killed is kind of like
last house on the left but from the
victim's point of view rather than the
perps point of view so i thought that
was kind of cool that was like a nice
inversion and i'm sure that was probably
done on purpose because like i said last
last house on the left which was
actually based on the virgin spring and
was it ingmar bergman yeah i want to say
but it's a so that story was based on
that so i like that it was kind of an
inversion of that and like i said i'm
pretty sure it was done on purpose so i
liked that about it um but yeah this is
actually if you like survival horror um
it's not doing anything new or anything
um but
it really is a good like just
attention-filled like violent you know
survival horror type of thing as i said
i think the first part of it when
michael fassbender's character steve was
still alive i found him i didn't find
him an unrealistic character but i did
find him frustrating because like i said
but you know if he hadn't acted the way
he acted there would have been no movie
because you know they would have just
been like oh those kids are obnoxious
let's get in the car and go someplace
else the end you know what i mean so
it's like the fact that he just kept and
but i don't know i don't that maybe that
is kind of realistic unrealistic because
i feel like
anybody else in that situation once you
went over there which i
i mean the first decision to do that
just go over there and tell them hey can
you keep it down i said one i wouldn't
have done that i just think that's dumb
and it's not gonna get what you want so
i wouldn't have even bothered um but
even if you did do that
once you've done it twice and they were
basically like yeah [ __ ] off you can't
tell us what to do that's pretty much
the end of it you can't do anything else
about it unless you're just gonna shoot
them all in the face so
at that point it just seems like okay
well we'll just leave and go someplace
else and have a nice weekend and then
we'll just go home and that will will
live happily ever after instead of you
know being stabbed in the nuts and
burned alive
pretty much um you know so there's that
whole situation so yeah so like i said i
did find it maybe it was slightly
unrealistic that he just kept on
trying to resolve the situation but you
know i've known some people that would
probably do that kind of stupid [ __ ] i'm
just saying it was really stupid like he
made some really dumb ass uh decisions
that really led to
him getting killed for sure and probably
it's implied that she got killed as well
even though like i said they don't
really show it but she does end up in
this house full of hostile people and
they take her off into this other room
and you can hear her like shrieking at
the top of her lungs so i'm sure they
did something horrible to her um so you
know so she he got both of them killed
so good job there steve uh because it
was actually all his fault because i
would will say too that it was also his
idea to go to the stupid lake in the
first place uh if they had just listened
to her and gone someplace else like to
an actual city uh instead of out in the
middle of [ __ ] nowhere in the woods
uh where there are a bunch of
[ __ ] feral children running around
then maybe everything would have been
all right but you know you can't have a
horror movie without people making dumb
ass decisions like that so yeah if you
like british horror if you like survival
horror if you like hoodie horror which i
think is really funny i don't know if
i've seen
i don't know i guess i've seen a couple
like that what was that one i kind of i
feel like it was french i feel like that
was like a hoodie horror too but i feel
like it's kind of like a british
subgenre i think uh what was that one
called cherry tree lane or something
like that i think that was hoodie horror
and there was like a few other ones but
i don't think i've seen any of them uh
so this is actually the first british
one i've seen uh but yeah i didn't even
know that was a subgenre and that's i
kind of love that but yeah so it's like
i said it's on tubey if you want to
watch it it's a really really good tense
like violent survival
horror movie like in the woods like it's
not doing anything original or anything
it just does its simple premise and it
just executes it really really well it's
just a really disturbing fast pace just
like a nasty you know ride kind of thing
and that's that's really good like i
said
things don't have to be super
complicated if you're gonna do a simple
story like this then you need to nail it
and i think this movie really really
does this is actually a really good one
and like i said i feel like it doesn't
get talked about a huge amount although
i did have a few people recommend it to
me uh so thank you for that because i
actually um i might not well i probably
would have got around to watching this
but it would have maybe taken longer if
i hadn't gotten more recommendations for
it but yeah this is a good one eden lake
from 2008 go check it out and i will see
you on the next flickers of fear
bye